Scottie's with us in Kalamazoo Michigan
hey Scotty how are you hey Dave I'm
great it's an honor to talk to you
changed my family tree home honors how
can I help
hey so my wife and I recently out of
debt that baby step 2 as of Friday
I've always only fund baby step 2
probably this month or the next and
we're gonna continue on the baby step 3
we're gonna save up for a down payment
on the house and we're not sure whether
we're gonna buy a house or build kind of
depending on what's on the market or a
year from now and we have a down payment
but I know you suggest a real estate
agent walking alongside us buying a
house for sure but in building a house
the process you know I've talked to a
building company for example and I just
don't know I read on your website that
you suggest the real estate agent in the
building process I guess but if you
could walk me through that process and
any other suggestions you have around
building a house I know the rules that
you give on buying a house but just in
the building process I guess I don't
know a whole lot about that and I like
the cookie cutter way of getting a house
I guess in a normal sense but aren't you
gonna get your first home oh yeah it'll
be a first time how old is you have one
apartment I'm 31 and she is 25 how long
you been married six years wouldn't
build a house I wouldn't know I wouldn't
bet the house is my first purchase I
would buy a house there's my first okay
okay unless you're a contractor and you
do this for a living or no because no no
building a house together can cause a
divorce but we've thrown kitchen sinks
at each other building through houses so
a lot of the decisions that we made but
yeah yes yes dear that is a lot of the
answer's no dear this is not in the
budget
what do you mean it's not in the budget
well we have a budget for this freakin
house and you're going over it oh but I
don't it stomp your it faced and it just
it's not just by house okay all right on
your first one and then then I would
build maybe as a second or third house
later on nothing wrong with it but it is
there's nine million details there's a
a lot of extra stress it's probably 5x
stress of just buying a house and you do
get a cool brand-new house that you
picked out everything that's very neat
but sometimes people are under the
illusion that that's going to last
because your dreams change almost by the
time you get the house finished so your
dream home your dream home is a moving
target and it's just I'm ok we building
the house I built a couple and it's in
you know it can be an enjoyable process
if you're a project management type
brain which that's way my brain works
anyway but so yeah all that to say
brand-new young couple married first
house I'd save up and just buy something
I really would I think you'll be glad
that you didn't have all that extra
stress he's got to be at least 5x stress
at least but to answer your question
further yes I strongly recommend because
it's 5x dress and because there's 5x or
10x the detail that you have to go
through that you have a good real estate
agent that knows about building that's
going to walk you through the whole
process and that's yeah having a real
stage and walk with you when you're
building a house is absolutely vital
especially if you've never done it
before now I grew up in the real estate
business I've run rehab crews I used to
buy and sell property for a living so me
building a house was kind of a
no-brainer it's not a hard process for
me but but you know having a real estate
agent in your corner if you've never
done that kind of stuff before while
you're building for the rest of you that
are thinking about buying a new home or
building a new home
yeah I definitely would have one in my
corner 100% of the time hey thanks for
the call